Here’s something weird: A conversation about balance in League of Legends changed the pro scene forever.
In 2016, pro players and team owners were mad that Riot Games kept changing their game
at the worst possible times.
And in their attempt to pressure Riot to re-think the way they patch their game around pro play,
they ended up changing the business model of league esports scene forever.
And the craziest part about that, and that we are responsible for it.
Sort of.
Kind of.
"No. No."
Maybe?
"Hell no."
A little.
"No."
2016 was a frustrating time for League pro players and team owners.
It’s not that the scene was stagnating, far from it, it was actually growing faster than ever
But there weren't a lot of people outside of Riot who were seeing the benefits of that growth.
See, League at that point was still a pretty risky venture.
Sure, it was one of the biggest esports in the world, but it was a pretty uncertain proposition
for a non endemic investor looking to get into the space.
Teams were still able to be relegated, and if you happened to put together a team that
wasn’t, say, good enough for the current meta, your investment went down the drain at the
end of the season.
(Casting)
And you didn’t even have to put together a terrible team to be at risk.
See winning is popularity, and if you had a team that was good enough to stave off relegation,
but not good enough to win most of their games, you weren't going to build up the kind of fanbase
that sponsors are looking for.
Naturally it was a hot topic going into the 2016 NA LCS Summer Finals.
So in an interview with Team SoloMid owner Andy "Reginald" Dinh, ex-pro Scarra asked him about it.
"Like what's your personal opinion on these types of last minute changes."
W-w-w-wait, can we get a zoom-in on that mic flag?
That's right. Scarra was asking that question for theScore esports.
Which if I'm being intellectually honest, means nothing, doesn't matter, and has nothing to do with the rest of
this story.
But, if I'm being petty? Which I will be. It means that that seemingly innocuous question is responsible for the
sh*tstorm that you're gonna hear about in the rest of this video.
Back to the interview.
"Well I mean, if you look at it from a fan perspective right they have a lot of fun
watching LCS and Worlds with new champions. It just gets all crazy seeing a bunch of new champions.
seeing a Darius and GP running around just killing everyone.
But like, from an owner perspective and a player perspective, it's honestly really discouraging.
In order to make like an easy example, I would probably say it's like... If you look at the NBA right, where they go
into NBA playoffs, it would be essentially changing the basketball's weight, and changing into like shooting a
bowling ball instead of a basketball. And a lot of my players, practice like 10 to 12 hours a day.
And it's not fun practice either 'cause they wake up at like 10. They do VOD review 10-12 and they scrim
from 12 to 9pm and then they play solo queue. They're pretty much really invested into this.
And all their hard work essentially goes away."
But Regi went a step further.
He pointed out that the constant meta shifts make it really difficult for a non-endemic investor to feel a team.
Particularly because they don't really understand the game.
"From a lower organization standpoint, a lot of the investors are buying into esports
because they don't understand how to navigate around. They don't understand what to do.
It's a lot harder for them, so they're losing millions of dollars by putting money into
something they don't understand.
That's with any investment right? If you don't understand a space and you put money into it,
then you're basically just taking a gamble."
And if the game is constantly changing with relegation as the punishment for getting the meta wrong,
That gamble is just too risky.
Needless to say Riot didn't love getting called out like this by one of their more prominent team owners.
See, Team SoloMid is the most popular team in North America.
And if Regi was railing on Riot. TSM fans were likely to follow.
But Riot didn't respond with a carefully worded press release.
In fact they probably wouldn't have said anything and handled everything behind closed doors.
However Riot co-founder Marc "Tryndamere" Merrill seemed to take Regi's comments personally.
In the original comment he posted to the League of Legends reddit, Merrill wrote, "Love me some Regi.
But if he's so concerned about the financial health of his players, maybe he should spend some more of the
millions he has made/makes from League of Legends on paying them instead of investing in other esports
where he is losing money?"
Merrill went on to criticize more of Regi's comments. Including saying that team owners did have the means
to pay players better, they were just holding out on them.
And that patches were being designed to make the viewing experience more exciting.
Not to balance the game better for pro play.
As you might expect, that didn't go over great.
Even though Merrill edited his post to tone down the language.
His glib, seemingly uninformed, and mostly unpopular comments spread across the League of Legends
community like mimetic wildfire.
And Regi was quick to respond. The day after Merrill's reddit comments he released a Twitlonger in which he
pretty thoroughly rebuked most of Merrill's points.
In particular, he had this rather scathing response to Merrill's assertation that Regi shouldn't be spending
the money he makes on League of Legends into other games.
"Most LCS teams lose money. Because stipends are stagnant, sponsorships for LCS operations are
shrinking and the cost of player salaries, content production, support staff and housing costs
are spiraling up."
Regi pointed out that sponsorship activation opportunities were scarce.
And that Riot's team stipends didn't even come close to covering the cost of operations for an LCS team.
And while teams had fewer ways to make money than ever, players' salaries were naturally going up.
As great players realized they could ask for more money from teams that wanted to win.
And again, outside investors just weren't interested in a system that could see them lose everything to just
one bad split.
Tryndamere came back with a twitlonger of his own.
Effectively walking back a lot of his claims and agreeing with most of Regi's points.
But the damage was done.
Public opinion had been pulled out from under Riot. And the time was right to instigate change.
Reginald made one more Twitlonger post on August 24, telling Merrill that a proposal from several NALCS
team owners and players would be in his inbox that day, ending the post with a hashtag. #LCSForever.
#LCSForever spread quickly too. With several NALCS team owners banding together under its banner.
And it seemed like for the first time in a while, they were going to the negotiation table with some form of
leverage over Riot.
But fans wouldn't get to find out exactly what that meant for a while.
It took until November for firm reporting to come out about Riot's negotiations with teams.
When Slingshot Esports published a letter from teams to Riot detailing some of their demands.
Among other things, the documents outlined some of the team owners proposals and responses to Riot's
proposals.
And by April 2017, we at theScore esports were reporting that Riot was getting ready to franchise
for the 2018 season.
Finally, in June, 10 months after Regi's initial interview with Scarra.
Riot announced franchising was coming to the NA LCS.
With no relegation, permanent spots for teams and revenue sharing.
"And we think this is great because for teams this will enable them to make better investments and more
investments into their squad.
And it should in theory help with competitive parity it gives revenues up and down the table.
And for pros. We think this is a big change.
Because it gives them upside and benefit from the growth of the league."
In the end, Regi's comments very directly led to Riot implementing a franchise system that has only been
healthy for the scene, and has helped all of esports too.
We saw franchising being discussed as a serious option for even more games' leagues and more non-endemics
putting their money into the scene.
Unfortunately it wasn't all roses and sunshine.
EU got kinda screwed while NA flourished under franchising.
In fact, Europe isn't getting franchising until 2019 after split after split of declining viewership,
revenue and players leaving for NA.
But franchising did happen.
And it was thanks, in part, to us.
"Where do you get off?"
Totally us you guys, definitely not that Riot was probably considering franchising
beforehand and that they only acted after a concerted effort from team owners and pressure from
fans in order to make the scene better and
even then only after nearly a year of negotiations... It was definitely us. Mission accomplished.
You're welcome?